der begriff vom blauen auge passt hier
im warmen haus
bekanntlich ist ja die parteifarbe der
asb und im grunde genommen ging ist der
cdu vor allem was die wahl in sachsen
angehen nur um 1 auf keinen fall hinter
der hfg landen und am besten mit einem
gewissen abstand wurde am fehlenden dass
es gelungen darüber freute man sich auch
hier im konrad adenauer haus
das war das eigentliche ergebnis der
heutigen wahl in brandenburg ist die
sache natürlich nicht so gut ausgegangen
aber da hatte auch niemand erwartet dass
die cdu vorne liegt generalsekretär der
cdu zehn jahre hat natürlich nichts
gesagt zu dem was sie ist
in beiden ländern nicht wirklich gute
abschneiden der partei von konrad
adenauer der hier ist hat figur hinter
mir steht für die wohnungspolitik
bedeutet auch dass überhaupt etwas
bedeutet das natürlich bedeutet ist ganz
sicherlich etwas denn zwei mal so
schlecht abzuschneiden wenn auch einmal
vorn zu liegen ist nicht gut für die cdu
man muss sich fragen wie gehen wir
weiterhin mit der afg um und wie können
wir verhindern dass diese partei noch so
viel stärker ist als wir die cdu die wir
doch eigentlich konservativen einsammeln
das ist ich denke in der cdu und das ist
das große ziel für die nächste zeiten
also mit nicht so sehr
von brandenburg und sachsen nur zielen
sondern das wird natürlich das ziel sein
dass in ganz deutschland zu verfolgen
ist und zu einem guten ergebnis zu
führen hat
[Musik]